um okay well one of the issues we have
today in the education system is we
don't have enough time to try and fail
failure is rendered invisible and we're
only allowed to see the success at the
end you try again you can fail again and
you can fail better fail forward and
fail early and often there's a tradition
of failure experimentation and
documentation we need to continue to
nurture lifelong learners and to
destigmatize failure failure and success
so we came up with a fail-proof epic
fail journal
which is
a kind of documentation tool for
students to
kind of learn from their mistakes and
our kind of mission statement with this
is to encourage documentation of
experiences in a way that will help
utilize visualize and understand
successes and failures so that you can
understand them and help you be more
productive in the future yeah so we do
we don't want we want them to take
agency and engage in the world and we
don't want them to do this without fail
like uh so we want to be more than a
journal uh more than a lab notebook but
less than like just a fixed lessons
because we want them to uncover these
themselves uh so we want to make
something that uh
they can that that they find to find the
way things break uh epic fails give info
that gives vital info to the next stage
so we want this to stay analog uh it's
important that uh you take this places
you wouldn't bring your computer or your
power book it's like you want to take
this into the field and be like
recording things as you go um so like in
some ways we want to maybe make it
weatherproof but other ways like maybe
it'd be good if it could like you could
also compost it or something you know
like and it might like grow i kind of
take your failures and make them grow up
to the next stage
so changing that f to p we can progress
prototype a lot of things
in the learning is the whole process
so to actually make this happen we can
create a team to
put the content in the
journal
notebook and
the best part of it is this that it's
easy everyone can use it it's also um
yeah yeah we're doing awesome
pre-printed templates or grids like
there might be stencils or stickers
depending on the age group but like
there might be prompts and visual
examples about how other people do this
process and we can engage with people in
the community to show how they feel
thank you so much you guys let's go on
over to your judges
i just realized the judges it feels like
a design critique because it's like so
perfect no it's set up
um so we're going to put the seed money
for per thing like this
we're the compost for the seed bunny
could you guys remember a little more
sorry
but the partnerships we were thinking
would be
schools um any schools so that every
um student has access to it and it might
be it might be sponsored by a community
organization or something to like
develop it but we're hoping to be able
to give boxes of them to like a class to
test it in a classroom or something like
that the idea is i'm just gonna say the
idea that we didn't get to mention in
our presentation is that um it's gonna
be used in the realm that's in between
school and the extracurricular
activities because in school you have
the structure of the classroom and the
teacher to support you at the ymca or
the boys and girls club you have that
structure to support you but in the
activities in between on the bus rides
when you're at the park things like that
when you're doing your um hobbies this
is where you kind of
make the the connections between what
you're learning about in the classroom
and how it's applied in the real world
and so this is kind of your tool that's
definitely the hope and we can see how
it's used and there's a thing where you
can like maybe you you make a prototype
and it can fail but can you take a
failure and make a prototype next like
can that go both ways so maybe if maybe
if it works in classrooms teachers can
use that to like have an alternate route
past f to turn your f into a p on your
paper so you're going to rely on already
developed literacy skills
um well that's another thing that we're
thinking about is that it can help with
that because by documenting you can
practice your writing your ability to
communicate visually you're drawing i
think there's drawing like drawing maps
like making playlists kind of like play
testing your own like cycles so then you
can see if it has replay value like was
that a mistake like is it make fertile
information like in doing those things
like it's not necessarily a written
journal it's a journal of just
communicating visually so whatever that
may be yeah but you might do fiction
experiments or something to like come up
with i mean surprised
we're thinking two different sides that
either it it has kind of like
something that you can compare and maybe
share online that does use a fixed
template but also always open space to
like id8 as well so but yeah
administrators and others to buy into
this just give it to your students first
and start from the bottom up have the
kids bring them in